boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan we
are still on site in New York City New
York on Manhattan and we are going to be
talking about the architecture of
dataflow so we're going to be talking
about all things media we're going to be
talking about all things future of
humanity I'm super excited and grateful
to be with John Patel hello hello thank
you for coming on to the show so good to
be here greatly appreciate it of course
and it's an honor to be here because you
have been a huge figure in this industry
over the last two decades and it's oh
for counting it's three man it's no it's
on the third since 92. I know well
really I started in 86 so
long journey so so older than I am in
the industry which means there's been a
massive accumulation of a wealth of
knowledge in John so this is exactly why
we sit down with people like John so
background on John founder of seven
companies all in the media space
journalism event production advertising
author of the search how Google and its
Rivals rewrote the rules of business and
transformed our culture also an investor
in 35 seed or series a in Media Tech
consumer mobile companies and he's also
the CEO and co-founder of newco
so let's start with a big history
synthesis of things you and I were
talking earlier and you made this really
interesting point we were talking about
how okay here's the human race we've
evolved on on Earth and we're now kind
of at this at this Tipping Point with
exponential technology 7.7 billion of us
now crazy so you were saying we're in
the kitchen with the oracle
yeah this is like my sort of uh I I run
down the transcript in the dialogue that
happened during that scene in The Matrix
for Neo is in the kitchen with the
Oracle and she's offering him cookies
and he's kind of like I can't believe
I'm talking to this like he's you know
he's been looking for this person and
she's just like you know I've seen a
thousand of you I might see a thousand
more you know how do I know you're the
one there's no reason for me to think
you're the one you're gonna blow it
humanity is gonna die out the world's
gonna end and then another one either be
back here like her sense of time is the
sense of time you know that physics has
uh which is you know essentially
Timeless whereas our sense of time is
like well we have an urgency to fix
things in the next 30 Years or we're
just the Neo who didn't make it and
there'll be another one in uh half a
billion years or so right and and I
think we're really at that moment where
we just came into the kitchen and like
the cookies are being served
we're just realizing that we have a very
big task ahead of us and we may not
actually complete that task yeah
and when there's too many people
distracted and not so many focused on
the ethical dilemmas that are the most
pressing of our time this is one of the
oops ways to right I mean I think you
know we've gotten to the point with the
technologies that we've invented and the
knowledge we've acquired where
um you know if you're spending time you
know watching things like your show and
you know reading certain books and
paying attention to certain thinkers you
can't but sort of come to the conclusion
uh that there is a you know alignment of
the tectonic plates happening and it's
time for us to change
a lot of things about
are assumptions that we maybe grew up
with and and and these this has to do
with our economic system our system of
governance or government
um you know our relationship to
technology
um you know uh our fixation with uh
religion there's a number of things that
we sort of need to adjust and really the
span of maybe half a Generation
Um and that's the kind of Rapid change
that has never really willingly happened
in human history it's accidentally
happened World War II you know in other
words we've had Wars that have changed
human history significantly but
interestingly we've never had
multiple existential threats at once and
we've got them now
we've got nuclear we've got AI you know
we've got uh synthetic biology you know
we've got a lot of things going on at
the same time uh you know yeah and and
all these things coming together uh
portend a much higher possibility that
we may screw it up
so that's a good way to start yeah it's
a good good way to start your job
um and and this is all the the areas and
this is why you're focused on
specifically these areas in the next
decade and so we're going to get to
John's focus in this um that he's
focusing on we'll get there in a little
bit I want to make sure to explain this
this trajectory three decades of this
trajectory for you from wired to
standard to Web 2.0
um to Federated Sovereign and new Co
give us a synthesis of how that what you
look what you what you did
yeah um
well when I was an undergraduate I um uh
studying cultural anthropology which is
you know self-referential uh uh you know
set of studies it's a study of mankind
um so studying Us and how we work
together culturally
um and during that period I was taught
kind of a fundamental lesson uh is to
understand our self through the things
we make
um and those are uh essentially
Technologies right now if you're an
archaeologist which is cultural
anthropology of the past you look at
artifacts and you say oh you know with
stone tool what can I what can I
understand about an entire culture from
this like small set of artifacts I've
dug out of you know the Gobi desert or
whatever right
um but if you're a cultural
Anthropologist you study the present
um and uh as I was studying that
um the Macintosh computer came out and I
you know newly trained to see all that
we make as artifacts I'm like well here
is the most important artifact in the
history of of humankind this right here
this computer I was convinced of it
um and fascinated by it for a number of
reasons as were a number of early
converts you know there there was like a
complete cult around the Macintosh and
so when I graduated I decided that
instead of trying to get a doctorate in
cultural anthropology which I was I was
considering that because I kind of had
an academic event I decided to become a
journalist because a journalist you kind
of write history in real time and um
that seemed kind of more interesting I
joined a startup magazine my first
startup it's not like on my resume
because I just joined as an intern
um but it covered apple and so I got a
chance for three years I kind of rose to
senior writer senior editor and so on to
to cover
apple and the Macintosh and networking
and graphical user interfaces and
databases and basically all the stuff
that became the web before well before
the web in the 80s okay you know but
those of us Deep In The Weeds there we
knew it was coming right and that laid
the ground for about three or four years
later I realized I was so on fire about
this but I didn't have the tools to
really write the stories that I wanted
to write I was convinced that the whole
world was going to change radically and
that no one really understood that and
it was really important I was like there
were I was I was not alone but there
weren't that many of us that were
convinced that technology was going to
change everything in 1989. yeah um and
uh so I thought I need to go back to
school so I went back to Berkeley got a
graduate degree in journalism and while
I was there you have to do a master's
thesis and the Master's thesis was uh
you know this one year thing where you
you know do some big project and I
wanted to start a magazine that I called
the Rolling Stone of technology
and that got shot down by my Dean so I
didn't start that but after I did I
wrote a long paper which you can find
somewhere but instead when I graduated I
was offered a job by the LA Times now
that's like the back in 1991 like
that was you know big paper great job
I hated it uh and I quit and I got a
phone call almost the same weekend from
this crazy man named Louis Rosetto who
was starting the Rolling Stone of
technology I mean he called it wired I
didn't have a name for it much better
name because I didn't have a name
um and he he asked me at the ripe age of
like 25 to be the managing editor which
was just you know
being prepared meeting you know it's
just luck and preparation right and I
was ready to do that and so wired you
know our purview at wired was to see
absolutely every single possible impact
that technology might have on everything
it did not matter it could be education
it could be medicine it could be you
know uh entertainment it could be
business did not matter we wrote stories
asking a simple question which was
what's going to change how's it going to
be right and we were so convinced that
it was going to be different and we were
so convinced it was going to be better
that you know the wired optimism was
kind of is a well-known you know fact of
of you know and matter of fact the
wild-eyed kind of optimists of the
California you know is everything's
gonna be great you know I think that uh
that set a tone or reflected a tone of
an industry the technology industry that
started to believe its own like
we're going to change the world we're
going to make the world a better place
you know we have these amazing new tools
and we're going to use them for good we
all believe that very very strongly
about five years after starting wire and
doing a whole bunch of crazy stuff as
part of that
um I got another idea uh which I pitched
to Lewis and and my partners there and
they're like it's a good idea John but
we don't really want to do it it's kind
of not a wired thing and it was a
economist for the internet
um and uh so I left to do that and I
started the industry standard and this
was essentially I want to say you had
this really cool a polymathic
look at because again you were seeing
technology but in education Healthcare
biology you started seeing Network and
but to me I've spent my whole career
following one story the impact of
technology on society right digital
technology specifically
um and I saw an inflection happening in
about 95-96 that where that was going to
break out the most sort of uh you know
uh in in the most dramatic fashion was
going to be in business right and so I
thought that story was really like the
story of technology and Society wired
was sort of writing the digital
Revolution like where their digital
where the rubber was going to hit the
road in the late 90s was the internet so
I left in uh 97 and started the industry
standard to cover that story and his
Weekly Magazine a daily website and
research and you know all the stuff you
do conferences all of that that was a
wild ride because that was the gogo.com
boom right that was 90
87-2001 where you know for the first
four years this thing grew faster than
any Media company in the history of
media I had the most ad pages of any
magazine in history
um and it was it was profitable in year
four made tens of millions of dollars in
profit we were going to go public uh
companies that had a tenth of our
Revenue had you know half a billion
dollars valuation so you know stars in
our eyes and big plans to take on Dow
Jones and businessweek and all that and
then needle scratched that because
you know it all fell apart with the.com
crash right and so we went from a 200
million dollar Revenue run rate to a 40
million dollar Revenue run rate in about
a quarter
um and that was a huge lesson to go
through that
um as an entrepreneur you know as a sort
of semi-public figure you know as a face
of this thing and all that
um we had 500 people we had we had
magazines in 15 countries you know it
was a big kind of thing but it was a
long time ago so 2001 I find myself with
uh you know a failed company uh you know
a sort of reputation uh I I hope a good
reputation in the industry as a starter
of things but you know also this thing
was a big failure Front Page New York
Times Wall Street Journal kind of
failure you know
um that's tough you know and with kids
and early 30s and you know and I just
couldn't believe what I was
reading which was sort of a celebration
that the internet was over
you know thank God it's just you know
it's just it's a good place to sort of
send email and communicate with people
and it's good distribution for our old
line businesses you know but it's not
going to be what all those people like
Patel were saying out there in
California especially New York where I
now reside where we are right now the
New York Press was almost throwing
parties that like the internet thing was
over because they were terrified that it
was going to upend their yeah you know
uh their their incumbent position
but I just couldn't really believe that
it was true
my faith in the story was like very
shaken but it wasn't broken and so in
I started looking for proof that there
that story still had legs right
um it was my story and I had spent you
know my early career really in it
um and I found it uh I found it uh in
two companies one was Google uh which at
which I knew from the industry standard
days we'd put it on the cover once
um before anyone really knew what Google
was and like 99
um 98.99 and then uh another was called
um Overture which is a google-like
company down in Southern California and
these companies when you visited them at
that time a 102. today we're going off
they were they were hiring people free
lunches everyone was happy doing great
work it was the opposite of the absolute
like pile of Ashes that the entire
technology world was in at the time and
so I'm like wow you know what's going on
here so I went deep into that
um and I learned a lot what I learned
was of course you know became the
subject of of the book The search but it
but essentially what I learned was we
were about to remake our relationship to
knowledge yeah you know humankind was
had had over the process of the early
internet and into the the first boom and
now even as the second boom was building
had rewired our ability to access
knowledge and that was super powerful
and important in laying the groundwork
for where we are right now and so I
wrote a book about it I started a
company
that Drew from its insights called
Federated media and I started a with a
partner Tim O'Reilly who's an amazing
dude started a conference to think about
it out loud and talk to the leading
lights of who are involved in this
process and we called that web 2 and the
idea of web 2 was there's a new set of
companies that are arising From the
Ashes of web one
that are you know leveraging the sort of
the fact that you know bandwidth is
getting better processing is getting
better new sets of Technologies like
Ajax were emerging that are allowing for
interactivity with information in real
time using the web and it seemed like we
were just at the cusp of making an
incredible open Connected Internet space
and it was super exciting all these new
sites and services we were launching all
these things were starting to share data
and make mashups and and it was just
like wow we're on our way again you know
and so that early optimism why are we
starting to pay off in the web to you
know uh Zone and so you know I started a
company that got you know very big and
very successful called Federated that um
I want to say the perseverance that you
had to get through I don't know if I
call it perseverance as much as I would
call it like I just need to feed my kids
like I I just in my head you know like
like and you also knew where to look you
went to the ones that were still
thriving in the Ashes to dig and find
that it was this big the fact that we've
collectively learned as Society to get
to now and then you went and figured out
that it the the internet is now we're
actually able to parse the collective
yeah we had it we had we had a
significant problem uh which you know my
current workers will get to is focused
on which is you know all of a sudden we
had access to all the world's data but
we couldn't make sense from it and what
Google became was a was a massive new
sense-making organ
right we have eyes we have ears we have
skin we have these sense organs that
we've evolved over hundreds of millions
of years
but we are we had begun to make digital
sense making organs and and anyone could
get one right you could add a Google to
your sense making organ lineup right if
you just get a computer and go on the
web and you could start to make sense of
things right you could start to refine
data into information and make sense of
that information make it useful to you
or to society I was totally into that
right and now one of the ways I
made sense of it was I made a company
that now narrowed from everything wired
business industry standard to Media
Federated media and I and my idea that
when I started the company in 04 2004
was
the relationship of the three parties
that really make up the media ecosystem
uh audience
Publishers and advertisers that that
relationship was completely being
renegotiated and I called it
conversational media that everyone was
talking to everyone else whereas the
mass media one-to-many approach to sort
of you know um uh monologue media versus
conversational media
um
and I started accompanying that space
and I recruited all the best blogs which
were the conversational media of the
time right because people left comments
and there was a whole linking you know
structure that had been worked out
people you know citation and and you
know one guy would write a post and
someone would respond with another post
and they'd link back to each other and
Google loved blogs because it helped
them understand interest and all of that
um so I started a company with the best
of those and helped them make money and
and deal with their ad operations and
all that stuff and that grew very very
large
um uh you know we got into the top 20 in
comscore we got you know it became a big
thing got a lot of money raised and and
you know everything was awesome
until it wasn't and and what happened uh
you know I'll I'll shorten this because
it's a long story
um we don't have any bourbon here but
you know
um what what happened really is that
about you know it grew and grew and grew
and everything was awesome uh we
rethought kind of the role of
advertising we came up with new
approaches to advertising we called
native advertising sort of in blog
stream you know sponsored content stuff
like that seems like duh now but back
then it was very novel
um and even though it really wasn't
because the idea of you know sponsored
content goes all the way back to PNG
doing soap operas and goes all the way
back to inserts and magazines and
newspapers or you know it's not a new
idea we adapted it for the media
but what we couldn't do and didn't do is
um we didn't think to become a
centralized
control point for everything
my great blind spot and and I hope
strength as well is that I believe in
decentralization yes uh and uh we
watched Facebook
from 07 really when it started to matter
throughout 12 we were growing like
gangbusters but it was about 11 12 when
they turned the news feed on and then
they put that ad unit in the middle of
the news feed and advertised and
automated the ability to buy an ad there
against audience
that undermined the independent web it
undermined what we stood for right we
had tens of thousands of sites that we
were repping at that point we had a huge
audience but they had an even larger
audience and the ability to you know
with the data they had to allow an
Advertiser to pick and choose any
audience member they want and have them
in a captive moment right and there was
very hard to compete with that so
um fortunately I saw that coming and
Federated had purchased a company uh
that was in the automated programmatic
advertising space
and in 2013 we spun that company out and
created a new company and moved all of
our cap table and key people into that
company sold Federated and that was
called Sovereign the idea was you're you
should be the Sovereign owner of your
own data right if you're a publisher you
should have control
and Sovereign goes on to this day and
it's still a struggle because Facebook
Google and Amazon are very dominant in
the in this market of data and
advertising
um but that that was Company Five
by this point I was starting to think
maybe I should not be starting companies
anymore you know maybe I should sort of
start investing which I had started
doing and maybe I should be on some
boards and I joined the board of a big
data company called Axiom now live ramp
and writing more and sort of thinking
out loud more and doing that kind of
stuff
um and I sort of started down that path
but I had this side project called newco
that I was doing it was a it was an idea
that
because of the web 2 boom almost every
college graduate from sort of 2010 on
had the option should they choose to to
become a CEO of a company when they
graduated all they had to do was like
you know borrow 5 000 bucks from their
parents get an AWS account you know get
a WordPress site put something up start
coding or hire someone to start coding
for them and there was a chance they
could be the next Mark Zuckerberg right
and everybody was doing it it was and
what I was noticing is there's too many
of them
not all of them are really driven by any
kind of purpose that has to do with
making the world a little bit of a
better place and there was a lot of just
like you know let me see if I can figure
out a way to you know
rent seek on parking spaces in San
Francisco you know there's a lot of
so I thought like maybe what we
should do is identify the companies that
are truly leveraging these technological
tools to create significant change in
the world we'll dub them new codes new
kinds of companies and we will identify
them celebrate them you know write about
them do videos about them you know that
was the idea of make a media platform
for new kinds of companies and
along those lines we did an event and
we've done it in 30 cities where we
identify those companies and they all
open their doors on a given day and it's
a big celebration of these kinds of
companies in a particular City they did
much better in small cities like
Cincinnati or larger cities but that are
not as connected to New York or San
Francisco like Mexico City than they did
in New York or San Francisco which is
really interesting
but beside that it was a great product
and a terrible business so it sort of
you know we tried we tried we tried and
we ultimately pivoted into a high-end
thought leadership conference and a
small media platform and so
um that kind of piece where you know the
mission of that of the company was
really to step up above technology and
look at what is the one Agent of Change
that might be the vehicle that we as a
society can use to cross the chasm we're
about to face right and to me that Agent
of Change is the corporation right and
if we're going to do that we need a
different kind of Corporation than the
one we currently have because since the
Milton Friedman School kind of took over
all of thinking uh in capital markets
really Reagan Thatcher in the 80s
profit seeking has been the number one
goal of Corporations and it's I'm going
to extract capital and I'm going to put
it in the pockets of my shareholders
that is the number one job of
Corporations and so the new co-ethos was
no that should be table Stakes making
money you got to do that to be a
business but maybe you need to make
other kinds of value besides money yes
and maybe you have more stakeholders
than just shareholders
so that idea is at the core of nuco and
my view was I should spend all of my
energy so I became full-time CEO of that
company it was a side thing for a while
but I you know trying to identify and
you know sort of shout from the rooftops
this kind of company we should be
emulating that kind of company maybe not
right so I was not a fan of uber before
Dyer came over but I was a fan of Lyft
you know I was not a fan of
um
you know uh I don't know I'm gonna make
something up now Colgate but I was a fan
of Unilever right there are companies
that are really trying to change things
and and so what I realized about three
or four years in is it's a really big
job number one number two I would have
to raise 10 or 20 or 30 million dollars
to do it right and number three I wasn't
that interested in doing that and that's
sort of the thing you can do when you're
a seasoned entrepreneur is make a
decision to not raise money as opposed
to a decision to just keep running
through walls which is what most
entrepreneurs do you know we're sort of
programmed to just not see obstacles and
then run into them until we get through
them around them over them under them or
redefine them as not an obstacle but a
feature you know so I just said you know
what no I don't want to run through that
obstacle so I pulled back from that last
year and I was thinking really deeply
about what do I want to do and I
realized what I needed to do in order to
answer that question was get out of the
space I had been in for so long which
was the valley
you know all the companies that I
mentioned and the book and every other
project I had worked on and all the
Investments for the most part were in
Northern California and it was time for
me to change the conversation that I was
in so my wife and I decided to move here
uh and that decision was made uh early
last year and we moved here in the fall
of last year yep and there's a huge to
two huge things that you talk about you
talk about uh the company the formation
of of companies that choose to rent seek
versus formation of companies that are
solving world's child pressing problems
huge difference between those two things
and it's really important for as we come
up with our moonshot ideas across the
world is to really keep that in mind all
the time another thing crucial that you
mentioned was the the Paradigm of of
capitalism and what the end what a court
what an entity of a corporation doing of
just taking funds and moving it to the
shareholders versus now it's about
solving those pressing challenges and we
see that a little bit with the benefit
corporations you see that a little bit
with some of the millennial and gen Z
drive towards looking at mission
statements of companies and putting our
money into those companies right and so
now you've made this move and actually I
I will agree with you actually quite I'm
I'm 26 I've only been in the valley less
than seven years still but I have seen a
lot of thought monoculture in Silicon
Valley and I'm I'm also very excited to
be in New York talking to different uh a
different thought culture here well I
mean the thing I say about the valley
and it's you know part of partially
ingest but but in all humor is truth is
that the that that the valley is a
company town and I don't mean like
it's a technology industry Town though
that is also true it is literally a town
that wants to talk about companies
that's all it wants to talk about so if
you you know one of the things that was
really starting to bug me and I was even
starting to take notes every time I was
in a meeting uh in my notebook I would
say no we're talking about companies
again so you'd start talking about an
idea
but it would always end up being how do
we turn that idea into a company are
there other companies that are already
doing that idea how can I invest in that
idea you know so it's always company
company how do I make a company it's
like you know what the point is not to
make a company right the point
is to figure out a problem the company
is the vehicle and if we over obsess on
the vehicle we forget about what we're
driving to yeah right and so like I
thought I need to get out of that
dialogue I love San Francisco I love
where I lived for many many years Marin
um I even love the valley although I
have some issues with sort of the
culture of the valley but I needed to
jolt myself out of it so because I knew
I had more work to do I just couldn't
enunciate it and I knew coming here uh
and forcing myself into a new
conversation would would sort of bring
it out of me and I think it has yeah and
I'm glad you also took a big leap into a
cold water pool yeah into into this
shock for you because now
um yeah your immerse your nervous system
is immersed in this in the environment
of thinking differently
um I I also just want to reiterate for
viewers that are that are my my age 26
and and younger it's it's difficult for
us to to get behind your eyes in the
eyes of so many others that were
actually there over these last three
decades of Technology going from that
first Macintosh all the way through the
dock I mean I was your age when yeah you
know when I when we were doing the first
edition of wired so
um yeah that's that was 25 years ago so
that's that's that's something
um yeah yeah and I have a son who's 22
and you know what did he do when he
graduated college started a company
it's like yeah that's what and you know
I think it's got a great idea and I wish
him well but you know I also have quoted
to him exactly how many of these
companies actually succeed but um you
know but he's very passionate about it
so this is a this is a in this pivotal
moment the slowing down to think about
what we're doing with exponential
Technologies and what we're doing with
geopolitics and how we can find a sense
of unity together is the most Salient
right now so okay so tell us about
what's going on okay we have now we like
to say it this way the the the the the
second uh the second greatest invention
of mankind is the data we leave behind
and the first greatest invention of
mankind is how do we measure that data
and make it applicable to our lives
right and it has yet to be invented and
so now you're obsessed with the
architecture of data flows and
rightfully so and we're trying to get
out of silos and into decentralization
and into actually making sense of status
so teach us about that I think it's time
uh I think we finally have uh
the right set of circumstances for
um
to to start to justify and defend
um some new answers to some old
questions right
um
first of all the second book that I was
working on that I abandoned in 2014 2013
2014 was essentially about uh trying to
understand the distinction between data
and information and the impact of data
on society and I could not quite get my
brain around it and and I'm a proxy for
my kind of what I would consider like my
readers you know if I can't do it then
it the time isn't right you know and
there's a lot of brilliant books that
were written before that period and
written since that are about this but we
haven't quite
been able to find the metaphors to help
us get to another place but I think
we're there now and I think one of the
things that's happened in the last five
years is number one most of the sort of
sentient population has realized the
importance of data you know you try to
tell people in 2013 how important data
is and they're like what the are
you talking about you know you try to
talk about you know how much data you
know Google or Facebook or Amazon has
about you in 2013 they're like it
doesn't really matter because I'm
getting stuff cheap or I'm my searches
are getting answered quickly or you know
I stay in touch with my high school
friends on Facebook what's the deal
what's the problem right people were
talking about it but it wasn't
an issue yet it is now it's a fun like
people have woken up and said holy crap
you know and now we're wondering you
know I've got Alexis and Google homes
around here you wondering you know what
are they listening to right people are
there's an ambient awareness of
information and data that just didn't
exist five years ago that's number one
number two we've started to solve a lot
of hard problems around distributed
architecture at scale
um and we've gotten a little over
excited as it relates to blockchain and
icos and all that stuff but the truth is
that this set of Technologies is not
nascent anymore it's developed and it's
starting to come up its own scaling
curve which is exciting so that's a
fundamental thing and the third thing is
we have existential crisis driving this
massive existential crisis that people
are waking up to we can't do nothing
about uh global warming
um we can't do you know nothing about
um the idea of a generalized AI we can't
do nothing about the impact of synthetic
biology we can't if we do nothing then
the Oracle in the kitchen will just
dismiss us and know that someone else
will be back in a few hundred million
years we're done right these are big big
you know potentially you know uh you
know civilization wiping technologies
that we've created and I didn't even
mention nuclear but they're still
nuclear right so and by the way you know
when the AI you know gets a hold of the
nuclear codes you know that's the
Terminator Series right
um so we have to
find a way to have a civil dialogue
about these issues and the way we find
it is through media
what you're doing right now
this is how we have the dialogue we need
to imagine
and create new forms of media
that you know it didn't end with
Facebook I'm sorry social media is not
the last form of media and if it is we
are true and well if true well and truly
okay so we need to keep going man
like if you're in the media business
like I am
you can't just stop and say okay well
you know first we invented you know the
pamphlet and then the newspaper and the
magazine and then we figured out
television and then we invented you know
the online publication and the internet
and email lists and and then video logs
and and then social media now we're done
no we're not we have to keep going we
have to come up with better media to
solve the problem that is in front of us
I've been obsessed with the role of data
and information in society for quite
some time in 2007 I wrote a piece called
the uh the data Bill of Rights
um and it listed sort of these I think
10 things that I think we should have
the right
to around personal information this was
not sparked by Facebook in 2007 Facebook
had just sort of flipped from being a
DOT edu service to being a generally
accepted service it was really because
of Google that I was thinking about this
stuff
um and so I've been thinking about this
for like 11 years really deeply or I
guess I wrote the book in o5 so earlier
but um
data flows according to rules
information flows according to rules in
the internet 1-0 kind of you know and
the web2o world that we had been part of
prior to now
um there was an assumption about how
that information would flow
and it was essentially a difference
between a Mainframe Computing
architecture and a PC internet
architecture so what are the main
differences well a Mainframe
architecture has uh two components
there's a big ass computer in the sky
it's really expensive and it's where all
the value is and then there are these
things called dumb terminals nodes
and what they do is you put data into it
and it goes up and gets processed by the
big computer in the sky and then the
computer will send back a program that
gets run on the dumb terminal to tell
the person putting data in what to do
it's it's a siled back and forth and the
nodes never talk to each other they'd
all talk to the master controller right
and that was the 1960s and 1970s in
Computing
because those big ass computers were
super expensive super valuable and
controlled by a big entity usually a
corporation right
then came along the PC Revolution and
the internet Revolution and all of a
sudden the intelligence and control and
value exchange at the center at the top
got pushed to the node and all of us
were in charge right and we were the
intelligence and we started sharing data
laterally yes right and so this
distributed Network approach to
information architecture
when I got involved in the internet in
93 94 you know well the internet I mean
I was on the well in the 80s and you
know copy serve and all that but the the
real internet as we understand it today
um we just assumed that that
architecture would continue forever
and what happened was it got
Consolidated and this has been sort of
Tim Wu has done a good job of this uh in
his books master switch and the curse of
bigness and the attention merchants
this consolidation occurred which is the
result of rent seeking
capitalistic you know True North that
say extract capital and put it in the
Pro in the pockets of shareholders so
what happened is the same cycle happened
to the Internet that happened to every
other medium and where did we end up
five biggest firms in the United States
are all technology companies and they're
all rent seeking data driven companies
right and so those corporations now own
and control
a vast Universe of information right
um and uh that architecture you know
that I describe all the power and
control up here and just sending an
application that we're just sort of data
inputting on this side and we're getting
that application sounds a lot like
Facebook right
um I can't take my Facebook data and
give it to you or give it to Amazon or
give it to a startup or give it to a
researcher or give it to whoever might
make value from it I can't because
Facebook has this big document called
the terms of service that won't allow me
to do that right
they say you own it but you can't do
that with it right so what we've
done is we've created a silent and what
they don't know what the big giants
don't know is that they could even be
making more they could be by taking a
percentage of that data that we would
own as a packet like you said a machine
readable and then distribute that and
the research like you pointed out too
it's so interesting to think about all
the missing research that is not being
done on this data so so I've been
thinking about this I've been writing
about this past couple years
um uh mostly in obscurity to be honest I
mean you know thousands of people read
what I write but not hundreds or
Millions you know hundreds of thousand
Millions but
um I've been sort of thinking out loud
Thinking Out Loud trying to figure out
how to put it all together and how to
make
some progress in this space right these
guys are seem so dug in that it's such a
kind of oligarchy now like our entire
ecosystem of of startup entrepreneurs
like you know dream of selling to one of
them really it's you know it's like the
odd company that is that makes it to an
IPO these days and it's usually in the
Enterprise space you know it's not in
the sort of consumer societal space it's
in the
Cloud security or you know some other
you know DocuSign right it's not it's
not you know but in any case
um
what I realized was there was this
shadow
Constitution that in the United States
particularly we without voting on it
without declaring it without studying it
without thinking about it we are
governed by a constitution as it relates
to how data flows around our society and
who gets to make value from it and we've
never really ratified this constitution
we've never thought about it very deeply
but it exists it's very powerful and
it's the product of this very strong
intertwined rope of technology and
capitalism right and that's what I was
studying at nuco and so it kind of all
comes together and I was like wow what
is this constitution right well I have a
theory which is that it's the terms of
service of the largest technology
companies and those terms of services
run 20 if not hundreds of pages you know
are written by lawyers to protect the
business model of current companies and
almost every entrepreneurial startup
except for the ones that are trying to
fight the system of which there are many
and they're great but they're very
difficult to do but almost all the
startup Community just copies those
because those are the successful company
so I'm going to write the same terms of
service that Amazon has because look at
Amazon they're crushing right so I'm
starting a startup I'm going to have the
same terms of service about how I handle
data data is the most powerful potent
resource so I'm going to hoard it so we
have this data hoarding
architecture in our economy right
I thought to myself what would be a
different architecture if we could just
go to the Whiteboard and build a new
architecture of how data flows around
Society what would it be right and I
imagined and you know not which is a
great question to ask across every sort
of industry is if you every industry if
you could rebuild a industry how would
you design it from scratch to make it
much better and and of course there's
huge problems getting from utopian you
know you know Perfect Design Land to
where we are now we can talk about that
but uh yeah but you know I looked at
Healthcare I looked at Financial
Services I looked at agribusiness you
know Ag and what was striking in all of
those from just sort of a cursory some
research that I did you know over the
last couple years is they all have the
same architecture they all hoard data
they all don't share it laterally and
they all are extracting capital from it
for the benefit of their shareholders
not for the benefit of society and so
now a lot of people have noticed this
problem I'm not like unique in noticing
this or talking about any of the
I'm talking about right
but one of the things that I think I'm
semi-good at is creating media and you
know
thinking out loud about well we have a
problem which we do about it or we have
an opportunity what should we do about
it that was wired that was the standard
that was Federated that was you know
even nuko I think what we have is the
opportunity to rethink some basic
regulatory gates in our society some
very simple things we could do to change
things they would be radical
there's no way that the tech oligarchy
is going to like this at all but it's a
very simple idea and I wrote a piece
about that just a couple months ago they
may actually end up liking it they may
end up liking it because I think there's
a strong argument to be made but I've
got to make it that's why I'm at
Columbia doing this research that this
is actually a 10x or 100x of their
business yeah but they've got to make
the transition to get there right so the
the simple idea and again I'm cribbing
heavily from the shoulders of many
Giants many of whom are Anonymous but in
the open source world in the distributed
architecture and blockchain world and
beyond
that if we just let the data flow
in an environment that is regulated not
by either a you know oligarchic company
or
by the government per se but by us yeah
with a environment of trust safety
security privacy built in
the things that could happen would be
extraordinary and so I've been writing a
series of pieces with examples of those
right
um You had this great image of a bunch
of valves that you control and right
right give to researchers more data get
paid for that data right and so people
often obsess and and right now they are
because people are so as I as we were
discussing earlier people are so sort of
woke to the power of data right your
privacy is imperiled you're not getting
paid if you're not getting paid or if
you're not paying you're the product
right everyone sort of woke to the power
of data so there's a lot of obsession on
well my data should be worth something I
should get paid I think that's the wrong
thing to pay attention to it's not
payment it's value yeah and how much
value could we unleash for society if
what could be known
is knowable so just an example and and
um imagine
we're here on a block in New York City
and one of the things I noticed when I
moved here is there aren't very a lot of
interesting restaurants in this
specific neighborhood there's a reason
for that but um that I understand but
there's a million reasons I don't yeah
and there's a million reasons why the
bankers who might back uh small
entrepreneurs starting a restaurant here
don't understand and customers don't
understand there's just a there is
knowledge lying on the ground but it's
not being picked up because we have
hemmed that knowledge into silos that
cannot be shared laterally so 50 years
ago you might have had to go and walk on
every door in the neighborhood and ask
the questions to people but now that
imagine I just moved to this
neighborhood which I did and I'm I have
a hankering to start a restaurant now
you know currently starting a restaurant
is as crazy if not crazier than starting
an entrepreneurial business in Tech
that's right it's like that the failure
rate is like 90 after year four so it's
crazy right so if you're going to take
your hard-earned savings and pour it
into a restaurant and hope it works
wouldn't it be good if you knew as much
as you could about what's going on that
might affect that restaurant you're
going to start down the block
what's knowable now that wasn't knowable
five years ago well imagine if you could
ask a question of the world and the
world answered it right so I'm going to
start a restaurant I think I might want
it to be an Italian Vietnamese mashup
restaurant right that's my idea okay
I've got a hypothesis we're talking
about
Enlightenment so I can use a little bit
of metaphor we've had a Renaissance in
data in the last five ten years a deluge
of data Renaissance everyone's awoken to
the amazing power of data well if
history Rhymes let's go back to the last
Renaissance right the last Renaissance
predated a very important moment in
human history called the enlightenment
right that was after the Renaissance
when all of a sudden we opened up and
realized the potential in the
Renaissance and then we thought about it
and we came up with something called
formulating a hypothesis
Gathering the data
testing the hypothesis against the data
sharing and being transparent about both
the hypothesis and the data so that
others can test it yes
rinse and repeat that's the scientific
method right and that has driven us to
the point of progress we are now that
has given us the microprocessor the
internet everything okay the scientific
method is at the core of all of that and
that is short-handed by the
enlightenment right so we've had a data
Renaissance we haven't had a data
enlightenment
right and so here's the Imagine scenario
imagine that if I want to start this
restaurant
I could say okay I'm going to go to the
I'm going to go to this great company
that started a few years ago called the
research board there is something called
that but let's just call it that anyway
the research board and I'm going to put
up a request for proposal or a request
for token okay
I want a thousand people who qualify in
my neighborhood right I'll just ring
fence it geofence it right within a mile
of where I live I want you to give me
your Uber data your lift data your Rezi
data your open table data your Yelp data
your search data all the data that might
in any way help me understand whether or
not having a restaurant here is a good
idea everyone who's driven by an Uber
going to a restaurant anyone who's ever
signed up to go to a restaurant around
here and then cancel then why what did
they eat how much did they pay what kind
of food was it right you know did they
do it once a week once a month once
every quarter you know how much money
did they spend all of a sudden I've got
all of this
data from all of these it's just out
there lying like fruit on the ground we
just can't see it now I can I can ask
questions of it I can make from that
unrefined data information that will
drive the creation of a physical thing
in the world called a restaurant and I
can take that data and if I'm smart
enough about it and there'll be a whole
ecosystem of people helping me be smart
about it I can go to a bank and go check
this data here's my token for why this
restaurant makes sense run that through
your algorithms and they do and
they go damn I'm going to back this
thing I'm going to give you a loan to
get your restaurant equipment right
right now it's just like well do you
have good credit and you know can I take
your house over if the restaurant fails
I'll just you know that's basically
where we are right now in our economy
but imagine if all this data laying on
the ground could be applied to that one
problem and 10 million others just like
it
it it just gets me so excited
yeah it's crazy that this data exists
and no one can use it it's crazy that
our economy is not flourishing
because it has the information to
flourish but we have not figured how to
release it yeah and that's what I'm all
about right now so the project I'm doing
at Columbia is trying to prove that we
have a broken architecture and there's a
better way and so I'm literally creating
a visualization based on the terms of
Services of the four largest firms in
the United States
All Tech firms right and saying here's
what their here's what they're allowing
and here's what they're not allowing now
let's compare them contrast them and see
what you could do could you do what I
just described the answer to that
question is no
you know and of course you know Uber you
know Lyft resi these these These are
smaller
and so they you know Uber not so much
but they they don't get as much but
the truth is they all have similar data
policies so you need to if you're going
to make change you first have to
understand where you're standing what's
a what's going on right now we need to
see that we have an architecture of data
control in this Co in this country that
is busted once we see that we can then
say we should change it how
and my idea is just one there's probably
a lot better ideas than mine but you got
to have at least an idea to you know to
sort of tell the story right
um You got to admit that we have a
problem it's number one of AA right you
know acknowledge of doing acknowledge
you have a problem and then
crowdsourcing Solutions and ideas to the
uh so that's the work with Colombia and
what's interesting is again history
rhyming
um or echoing when the.com crash
happened I not only you know sort of you
know for a couple years it was rough I
was at I went to Berkeley and I started
teaching at Berkeley and I started
studying and and I ended up ultimately
writing a book I started studying search
because I just thought that was the most
important and interesting thing
happening in a world that seemed
completely up and broken at the
time right now our world doesn't seem so
great I'm sorry even though employment
is you know at record lows it's not good
employment and even though you know uh
you know me and my friends are doing
pretty well because we're highly
educated and we've been successful in
our careers most people aren't doing
very well we've got a broken society and
I in a few it feels that way to me
especially when you go to New York and
you know you can't like live in Marin
and in Silicon Valley and kind of be you
know insulated from it it's right in
your face here you know it's
very real what's happening and so what
can we do to fix our political system
what can we do to fix our Technologic
system the two are absolutely
irrefutably interconnected now yeah and
so we we you know the work has to be
what is the you know what's the rock we
could lever off of what what can we
identify that is something that can
change the conversation right and and
that's that's what I'm focused on so the
work at Columbia is all about that and
it's not driven by any commercial like
it's just I want to know this I want to
see this I want to see what the world
thinks of it you know sure and and and I
think it's going to lead to something
else you Illustrated this really
interesting
dude these this fruit that has these
fruit that have fallen from the trees
these data fruits invisible fruits these
invisible fruit that have fallen from
the treason the the creative potential
that exists across all of the different
fields if we can just
forage those fruit and and then put them
in different
um
uh
assemblies right that can then that can
then provide us with social value what
we need for that to happen besides sort
of political will which is very
important
um so I I realize I haven't kind of
talked about the one kind of the one
line that we need to change in our
architectural code a regulatory code
I'll get to that in a minute but what we
need technologically to do that is we
need the ability to create a trustless
environment
in other words not no trust but you
don't have to worry about trusting it
right we need the ability to that I did
you know billions of consumers of
citizens and consumers can trust an
environment that they can manage their
own security that they know that this is
that that as they share this information
it's secure that they can revoke it you
can turn it off turn it on turn it off
and that their economics associated with
it all those things need to be true we
need to invent Technologies to make all
that possible guess what we have we
literally have already solved all of
those problems for other things right so
we don't have a technological reason
that the system can't happen we have
a a cultural reason we have a societal
reason we have an economic reason
but the one line of code that needs to
be changed is simply this
and this is sort of under let the data
flow right yeah
um every
data service
at scale because I don't think you
should tax like the startup necessarily
but I think every startup If This Were
true would already build this into what
because they want to get to scale right
every data service at scale
must allow
their customers
to create
tokens that encapsulate all data created
co-created with the service into a
machine readable portable
vehicle that they can share with whoever
they want so my entire Amazon purchase
history my entire you know Run and Ride
history on Strava my entire ride history
on Uber anything that I do with that
service
turn it into a token machine readable
and portable and so there'll be a
standardized system yeah I'm not worried
about we we invented a really good one
called the internet you know where I can
just give that token to a startup that
wants to try to do something cool with
my Amazon data or give it to a
university that's trying to study
something that has to do with my Amazon
data or give it to a non-profit that is
trying to crack a really hard problem
because my data is somehow relevant to
them and I have the ability to turn it
off
remotely and I have the ability to get
value from it and I know that it's
secure and I know that the party that's
taking my data doesn't actually have it
they have access to it very important
distinction right we've solved this
problem it's called the ad Tech
ecosystem it's built it's built
my little company one of my companies
called Sovereign does nine billion
requests a day
a day
so we've solved this big processing
based on parameters and rules thing
right securely
it's not even blockchain
could be probably should be but it's not
so it's also the ad Tech base business
is a little bit gray in many of its
areas as we well know but we can do this
so
the proposed method the token act I call
it the token act it's like very
interesting the problem is the tokens
are so corrupted because of the Ico
stuff I've got to come up with a better
name but it but you've formulated in a
way that it gets people to understand
that their data is worth value for
society in so many different ways right
and it's also worth value for the
company to open up their data silos and
then this this this single
machine readable format across different
you get your your token again of of your
driving data through Uber or your
purchase data through Amazon I also
wanted to indicate this as well that
this is so Everyone likes to live
healthy everyone finds living healthy to
be something that's extremely important
to them and they we and we're starting
to understand that we spend so much
little amount of money on preventable
health care and medicine that we Now
understand that if we can turn on the
the data flows of our Biometrics out for
research perfect place where this this
kind of a regulatory framework which is
what this is people go oh regulations
it's terrible it's there's a
regulatory framework called
no regulation that is a regulatory
framework so get over it no matter what
we're in a regulatory framework a
regulatory framework is simply the uh
structures we create to ensure that we
don't dissolve into entropy okay that's
what a regulatory framework is it's like
how we can our bodies are regulatory
Frameworks right and so why aren't we
taking the data off our bodies in real
time and and and and and making
ourselves healthy because we have a
sclerotic bad architecture of
information control in the health
business who built the data information
and architectures in the health business
insurers
why because they're the ones that pay
that's 1950s capitalism controlling 2020
outcomes and that's you know
and and by the way we have 1950s
capitals and controlling outcomes in our
technology Industries as well and so we
have to change that core architecture
that's what the argument is of my work
at Columbia we're really looking forward
to that in the research with Colombia
we're really looking forward to doing a
follow-up on this John couple quick
questions that we like to go through on
the way out of the show
um first question is
let's start with uh
what is a core driving principle of
yours
core driving principle of mine
work on stuff
you can't help but work on like
if nothing's getting you excited do
nothing like
I've never worked on anything a company
piece of writing
that I am not
stoked about
sorry I'm Southern California guy yeah
um but like I think that as it relates
to work
and then personally
never with your family
those are kind of two core principles
yeah I don't do anything
that is against you know that messes up
your life with your family yeah
and if you let which you're kind of
trying you're doing this right now but I
want to see all the way back let's bring
the Whiteboard all the way back so if
you could rebuild civilization from
scratch how would you design it
I've never thought of that question I
mean I've studied civilizations right I
was like my undergraduate major
um
I could design it
how would I design it
I think
um I think the greatest impediment
to
civilization
is otherness is a sense of otherness
and one of the greatest strengths of
humanity is a sense of otherness right
so this idea of the individual is that
has that we have of each of us as being
other like I am separate and apart from
you
um it's sort of one of the remarkable
things that makes us interesting
um and when we combine that socially one
of the things that everything up
right so I think if I could go back and
uh
redesigns you know civilization as you
say
I might if I were such a God give the
gift of everyone who initially is part
of the first civilization I guess
a overwhelming knowledge that the other
is okay you know that the other is not
someone who's gonna steal your
kids kill your wife
kill you and take your that the
other is just you with a little bit of a
different spin that's worth checking out
because I think we you know we're still
acting so tribal and you know
and I don't want to lose this essence of
of of you know I'm not an advocate of we
should all just dissolve into Oneness
but I do think that we need to
understand that we are all one yeah
right and so somehow
that philosophical concept which took
Millennia to to really start becoming
something that could be discussed
publicly without getting either shot or
laughed at
I would give the gift of that early
yeah
well said and do you this wouldn't be
simulation if we didn't ask you do you
think we're in a simulation
hmm
yeah I really struggled with this one
I think that the technical answer is yes
but I think it doesn't matter why why is
it yes because one could argue that you
know given what we don't know
um if there is a chance we don't know
then it's technically possible in other
words we don't know what the ultimate
rules of the universe are we don't
we know that all scientists acknowledge
that all true scientists who are
scientific method driven scientists say
we don't know like how the
Universe Works sorry we don't know you
know but we're understanding the code
which is we're start we're yeah we're
we're you know we're pushing our way
toward that understanding but right now
we don't know and since there's a chance
we don't know there is a chance it's a
simulation right and if there's a chance
there's a simulation you know I'm going
to say it probably because I like the
idea that it probably is but the fact is
I mean look we started this conversation
talking about you know the Oracle in the
kitchen and the cookies that's right
that was a simulation the whole thing
right and that's what the chesky
brothers were actually asking you know
is this all just a simulation or is it a
system that just keeps repeating right
well if the system just keeps repeating
it could just be a button on someone's
coat you know and so even if it's not a
simulation it's just a button on
someone's coat you might as well call it
one because that's what you know so
there's just this you know the it's like
the end of you know Men In Black with
the aliens and the marbles like you know
there are these ineffable questions
right
um I prefer to answer them in a way that
uh makes it
sort of fun to stroke a chin
and last question is what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
the first idea that came up was my wife
giving birth I know that's totally
like cliche but like you just asked and
I just like saw my wife holding our
first kit
so but
the most beautiful thing in the world
passed the cliche
is when you're in the flow
you know like when you completely lose
your sense of self and
but at the same time you're well aware
that you're in something that's bigger
than you but you are making it happen so
there's this cycle that's happening
about you and the flow and the flow's
not you but you're in it and when you're
in that that happens to me when I ski
when I ride
bikes when I practice yoga when I write
you know a piece
um and when I get into conversation like
this like that flow is the most
beautiful thing in the world then we
should all pursue it it seems like the
deepest cognitive instinct is that yeah
it seems like that is what brings us
meaning if we can hone in on that yeah
get in there man get in there and stay
in there as long as you can that's why
people are lifelong Surfers
you know John this has been such an
enlightening conversation we are very
much looking forward to the new
architectures of data flows John thanks
again all right thank you Michelle great
I appreciate it thanks everyone for
tuning in hugely appreciate it as well
give us your thoughts in the comments
below we'd love to hear from you let us
know join the community chat let's get
talking about these Concepts and coming
up with our ideas about how to solve
some of the most pressing challenges
going on in the world Inspire these
conversations around you check out
John's links Below in the bio check them
out also join us in supporting
simulation so we can continue coming on
site to great places and talking to
incredible leaders like John and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
destiny into the world build create
execute we love you very much and we'll
see you soon peace
that's it all right man that's it that's
how we do thank you brother that's how
we do